Welcome to "English in a Minute" where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
If you have ever heard American English before, you may have heard this:...
..."Keep your chin up."
What does this mean?
Let's find out by listening to an American English conversation.
I don't know if I can take any more.
First, my car broke down.
Then I was late for work.
And now my boss is mad at me for being late.
You'll have a better day tomorrow.
Just keep your chin up.
"Keep your chin up" means to keep your spirits high and remain cheerful in a difficult situation.
"Keep your chin up."
This is an informal expression that can be used in any situation...
...and everybody in America will understand you.
And that's "English in a Minute."